- Ici, on aménage une salle
d'attente. Juste à côté, on
construit une salle d'opioioion.
Nous sommes au centre de centre
de chirurgie RocklandMD, une
clinique privée qui pratique des
chirurgies payées par le réseau
public, et qui doit doubler
le nombre de salles d'opération.
- Là, on va être rendus à huit
salles d'opération. Il y en a
trois qui vont être dédiés àla .
- Chirurgie RocklandMD est
devenu un sous-traitant
essentiel du réseau public.
DANIELLE McCANN, ministre de
la Santé et des Services sociaux
- Oui, on est dans un mouvement
de délestage des activités qui
sont pas urgentes.
- Depuis le début de la
pandémie, on repousse de
nombreuses interventions
chirurgicales.
Plusieurs salles d'opération du
CIUSSS du Nord-de-l'Île-de-
Montréal sont fermés. Cette
clinique a donc augmenté la
cadence. Depuis juin 2020,
15 000 chirurgies auraient été
faites ici pour l'établissement
public.
Dr PIERRE Y. GARNEAU, chef de
la chirurgie CIUSSS
- C'est névralgique, on ne peut
plus vivre sans ça. C'est... je
veux dire, on ne peut plus
jamais revenir en arrière parce
que la capacité
d'hospitalisation n'est plus là,
la capacité du bloc opérat
n'est pas là. Problème de
personnel...
- Ça force plusieurs hôpitaux
à sous-traiter toujours plus.
C'est maintenant environ 15 %
des chirurgies payées par
le secteur public qui sont
réalisées au privé.
- La vitesse d'exécution, c'est
sûr et certain.
- Sans les balises imposées par
les appels d'offres, le privé
s'ajuste plus rapidement que les
hôpitaux publics.
- Les budgets, les approbations,
les modifications, on ne voit
jamais le jour. En "running
gag", on dit toujours : je vais
être mort avant de voir un
nouveau bloc opératoire.
- La pandémie a aussi forcé
Québec à majorer les salaires
des employés, surtout les
préposés, en plus d'une vaste
campagne d'embauche pour contrer
les pénuries dans le secteur.
La pandémie a aussi éloigné
les patients de leur médecin
de famille souvent déplacé
sur le front COVID. La Docteur
Emmanuelle Huchet revient à
des consultations en présentie
mais on est très loin de
la situation pré-pendémique.
Dre EMMANUELLE HUCHET,
dir. médicale, Clinique L'
- Je vous dirai qu'on est pas
mal 80 % sur place, puis
peut-être 20 % au téléphone.
- Avec une clientè
très vulnérable, la télémédecine
a de réels avantages.
- Continue comme ça parce que tu
as vraiment un
amélioration de 25 à 6 bières.
- Docteur huchet et l'infirmière
font un suivi à distance avec
Michel qui combat certaines
dépendances. Au début de
la pandémi
à distance sont devenus
incontournables.
- J'ai m m m m m m m moi, qui se
retrouvaient seuls, qui se sont
retrouvés seuls pendant des
mois. Le seul contact, c'était
nous qui les appelait.
- Et ils restent toujours très
importants.
MARIE-ÈVE BARIL, infirmière,Clia
- J'ai plusieurs patients qui
me le disent ouvertement :
j'aimerais mieux pas me
présenter. Présentement,
j'ai peur.
- Malgré ses progrès provoqués
par la pandémie, certains
retards restent très importants,
comme par exemple
en informatique.
- Je vous dis qu'on fax encore
des requêtes en 2022 dans le
milieu médical et ça a pas
beaucoup changé.
Ici David Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal